the matzah biele adds stricter my diet
means many of these ants days are spent
in dangerous raids on these combative
insects the termites are no pushovers
which leaves many ants wounded after
each raid researchers recently found
that injured ants are often carried back
to the nest by their fellow soldiers now
they've discovered that once back at the
nest the injured ants wounds are treated
by their nest mates who spend time
grooming the open wounds to clear debris
adding antimicrobial chemicals and
removing any pesky termites and the
treatment works it's treated within the
first hour had a mortality rate of 10%
well ants that received no treatment had
a mortality rate of 80% researchers
found that lightly injured ants altered
their behavior when near a returning
column of hands when nest mates were
closed they slowed their pace
dramatically signaling that their
injured if the ants passed them by
without help the injured and immediately
started walking faster following them
back to the nest ants that lost 5 or
more limbs in a termite battle or rarely
helped back to the nest normally when an
injured ant is found it curls up into a
ball to allow for easy transport back to
the nest heavily injured ants
however flail their remaining limbs
about and spin on their backs becoming
so uncooperative that they're left
behind moving forward researchers hope
to find out if this grooming behavior
simply prevents infection after termite
skirmishes or if it could also be an
effective treatment if an infectious
disease attacks the colony
[Music]
[Music]